Un hombre blanco de clase media, sin raza, género o clase.
Podríamos generalizar que soy universal.
(Risas)
A partir de ahí, me convertí en un hombre blanco de clase media.
La raza, la clase y el género ya no era algo sobre otra gente
sino sobre mí.
Y empecé a pensar sobre esto
y que era un privilegio que me había hecho invisible mucho tiempo.
Me encantaría decirles que la historia terminó hace 30 años
con aquel pequeño grupo.
Pero hace poco, me acordé otra vez en la universidad donde doy clases.
Una colega y yo impartimos un curso de sociología de la igualdad
en semestres alternos.
Ella da una clase como profesora invitada en mi curso
y yo una clase como profesor invitado en su curso.
Así que entré en su clase a dar una conferencia
con unos 300 estudiantes.
y mientras caminaba, uno de ellos me miró y dijo:
"Por fin, una opinión objetiva".
Durante todo el semestre, cuando mi colega abría la boca,
mis estudiantes veían solo una mujer.
Quiero decir, si les decía,
"Hay una desigualdad estructural que se basa en el sexo en EE. UU.
replicaban, "es normal que digas eso.
Eres una mujer y por tanto imparcial".
Mientras que si era yo, decían, "¡Vaya, qué, interesante!
¿Entrará en el examen? ¿Cómo se deletrea 'estructural'?"
(Risas)
Espero que todos vean
que esto es ser objetivo.
(Risas ) (Aplausos)
Pura racionalidad occidental.
(Risas)
Por cierto, creo que es por eso que los hombres llevan corbata.
Porque si vamos a personificar la racionalidad occidental pura
necesitamos un significante
¿y qué mejor significante para la pura racionalidad occidental
que una prenda que apunta con un extremo a la nariz
y con el otro extremo a los genitales?
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Ahí está el dualismo mente-cuerpo.
Por tanto visibilizar el género a los hombres
es el primer paso para que estos participen de la igualdad de género.
Cuando los hombres oyen hablar de igualdad por primera vez
y empiezan a pensar sobre esto,
muchos de ellos piensan
que es correcto, justo, lo que tiene que ser;
un imperativo ético.
Pero no todos.
algunos hombres piensan —cuando ven la luz—
"Sí, Dios mio, igualdad de género".
Y rápidamente empiezan a explicarte tu propia opresión.
Contemplan el apoyo a la igualdad de género como un calvario,
algo como, "gracias señoras, por hacernos reflexionar sobre esto,
a partir de ahora, lo tendremos en cuenta",
El resultado es el "síndrome de autocomplacencia prematura",
como me gusta denominarlo.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Sin embargo, hay otro grupo que se resiste a la igualdad
porque la ven como algo en detrimento de los hombres.
Estaba en un programa de TV con 4 hombres blancos frente a mí.
Así empieza el libro que escribí, Angry White Men.
Eran 4 hombres blancos enfadados
que creían que los hombres blancos en EE. UU. eran víctimas
de una discriminación inversa en sus puestos de trabajo.
Contaban lo cualificados que estaban para el trabajo,
para que los ascendieran,
pero no lo consiguieron y estaban muy enfadados.
Le cuento todo esto porque me gustaría que escuchasen el título
de este programa en particular.
Era la frase de uno estos hombres
y la frase decía: "una mujer negra me robó mi trabajo".
Todas contaban sus historias
lo cualificados que estaban para el trabajo, los ascensos
y se enfadaron al no conseguirlo.
Entonces era mi turno de palabra.
"Solo tengo una pregunta chicos,
sobre el título del programa".
'Una mujer negra me quitó mi trabajo'.
En realidad, se trata solo de una palabra del título,
me gustaría saber porque "mi".
¿De dónde salió la idea de que era su trabajo?".
¿Por qué el programa no se tituló "una mujer negra consiguió el trabajo"
o "una mujer negra consigue un trabajo"
Porque sin cuestionar ese sentido del "derecho" de los hombres,
nunca entenderemos por qué tantos se resisten a la igualdad.
(Aplausos)
Vean, creemos que es a nivel del terreno de juego
y cualquier política que lo incline aunque sea un poco,
enseguida pensaremos: "Ay, Dios vamos contracorriente
es una discriminación inversa contra nosotros".
(Risas)
Permitánme ser muy claro:
Los hombres blancos en EE. UU.
son los beneficiarios del mejor y el único programa de acción positiva
en la historia del mundo
que se llama "La historia del mundo".
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Después de señalar algunos obstáculos para que participen los hombres
¿por qué deberían apoyar la igualdad de género?
Desde luego es justo, correcto y es lo que debería ser.
Pero es mucho más.
La igualdad de género nos interesa también como hombres.
Si escuchamos lo que dicen los hombres sobre lo que quieren en sus vidas,
la igualdad, en realidad, es una forma de lograr la vida que queremos vivir.
Para los países es buena esta igualdad.
Según la mayoría de los estudios,
los países con mayor igualdad,
son también los que tienen mayor índice de felicidad.
Y no es porque todos estén en Europa.
(Risas)
Incluso en la propia Europa, los países con más igualdad
tienen los niveles más altos de felicidad.
También es buena para las empresas.
Las investigaciones de Catalyst y otros demuestran irrefutablemente
que cuanto mayor es la igualdad de género en las empresas,
mejor es para los trabajadores.
Los trabajadores son más felices.
El volumen de trabajo pendiente y la desgana son también menores.
Es más fácil contratar gente.
El nivel de permanencia es más alto y el grado de satisfacción mayor,
con tasas de productividad más altas.
Por eso, lo que preguntan a menudo las empresas:
"Esto de la igualdad va a ser algo muy caro, ¿no?"
Y digo : "Para nada, de hecho, lo que tienes que calcular
es cuanto te cuesta ya la desigualdad de género.
Es muy, pero que muy cara".
Por eso, es buena para los negocios.
Y también es buena para los hombres.
Es buena para el tipo de vida que queremos llevar,
porque los hombres jóvenes, sobre todo, han cambiado mucho.
y quieren vidas animadas con relaciones fantásticas e hijos.
Esperan que sus mujeres, sus esposas y sus compañeras,
trabajen fuera de casa,
comprometidas con sus carreras al igual que lo están ellos.
Les daré un ejemplo de este cambio.
Algunos pueden que lo recuerden.
Cuando era bastante más joven nos planteaban un acertijo.
Puede que incluso en algunos aparezca una mueca al recordarlo.
El enigma era más o menos así.
Un padre e hijo van en auto por una una autopista,
cuando sufren un terrible accidente.
y el padre fallece.
Y mientras le llevan a la sala de urgencias del hospital
el médico en la sala, mira al chico y dice:
"Es mi hijo, no puedo atenderle".
¿Cómo es posible?
Nos dejaba perplejos.
No conseguíamos resolverlo.
(Risas)
Así que hice un experimento con mi hijo pequeño de 16 años
y un grupo de sus amigos que que rondaban por la casa hace poco,
mientras veían un partido en la TV.
Así que les planteé el acertijo,
solo para ver y calibrar el nivel de cambio.
Los chicos de 16 años
inmediatamente se giraron y me dijeron: "Era su madre, ¿no?"
Sin problema, tal cual.
Excepto mi hijo, quien dijo, "Podría tener dos padres".
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Es una señal de cómo las cosas han cambiado.
Los chicos jóvenes esperan equilibrar trabajo y familia.
Quieren esa dualidad de carrera y pareja.
Quieren encontrar un equilibrio entre la familia, el trabajo y la pareja.
Quieren estar implicados como padres.
Parecer ser que cuanto más igualitarias son las relaciones
más felices son las parejas.
Los datos de psicólogos y sociólogos son bastante persuasivos a este respecto.
Tenemos que ser persuasivos con las cifras y los datos para probar a los hombres
que la igualdad de género no es un juego de ganar y perder, sino que siempre se gana.
Eso es lo que reflejan los datos.
Cuando los hombres empiezan a participar,
equilibrando trabajo y familia,
solemos usar dos frases para describir lo que hacemos.
Nos ofrecemos para ayudar y ayudamos.
(Risas)
Les propongo algo más radical.
una sola palabra: "compartir"
(Risas)
Porque aquí están los datos:
Cuando los hombres comparten las labores del hogar y los niños
los niños van mejor en la escuela.
El nivel de absentismo de los niños es más bajo
y consiguen mejores notas.
Hay menos probabilidades de diagnosticarlos con THDA
menos probable que vayan al psiquiatra
o que tomen alguna medicación.
Al compartir los hombres el cuidado de los niños y las tareas domésticas
los niños son más felices y saludables.
Y los hombres es lo que quieren.
Cuando los hombres comparten las tareas de casa y los niños
las esposas son más felices ¿vale?
Además de ser mujeres más sanas.
Son menos propensas a ir a un terapeuta
que les diagnostique una depresión
o tomar algún medicación y seguro que irán más al gimnasio.
Se sienten más satisfechas en el matrimonio.
Cuando los hombres comparten el cuidado de la casa e hijos
las esposas son más felices y saludables,
Y sin duda, es lo mismo para los hombres.
Cuando los hombres comparten las tareas domésticas y los hijos
los hombres son más saludables.
Fuman y beben menos y consumen menos drogas.
Tienen menos tendencia a acudir a urgencias,
y más a ir al médico a controles rutinarios.
Irán menos a un terapeuta,
es menos probable que se les diagnostique depresión
y tengan que tomar algún tipo de medicación.
Los hombres que comparten niños y casa,
son hombres más sanos y felices.
Y ¿quién no querría eso?
Y por último,
Cuando comparten casa y niños,
los hombres tienen más sexo.
(Risas)
De estos 4 fascinantes hallazgos,
¿cuál les parece que se publicó en la portada de Men´s Health?
(Risas)
"Las labores del hogar la excitan".
No cuando es ella quien las hace.
(Risas)
Les dire, solo para recordarles a los hombres entre la audiencia
que los datos se recogieron en un período de tiempo muy largo,
así que no quiero escuchar,
"Vale, fregaré los platos esta noche".
Los datos se recogieron en un periodo de tiempo muy largo.
Pero muestran algo importante.
Al publicarlos en la portada la revista Men´s health,
lo llamaron también —seguro que les encanta—"Juegos de amor"
Lo que descubrimos es algo muy importante.
La igualdad de género
es algo que interesa a los países,
a las empresas, a los hombres,
a los hijos y a las esposas.
La igualdad no es un juego de 1 a 0.
No se trata de ganar o perder.
Es una victoria siempre para todos.
Y lo que sabemos también
es que no se puede empoderar a las mujeres y a las chicas,
sin que participen también los hombres y los chicos.
Está claro.
Mi posición es que los hombres
necesitan las mismas cosas que las mujeres han identificado,
que necesitan llevar la vida que dicen que quieren llevar
para vivir la vidas que decimos quereremos vivir
En 1915, la víspera de una de las manifestaciones sufragistas
en la Quinta Avenida de Nueva York,
un escritor de esa ciudad escribió un artículo para una revista
con el siguiente título,
Feminismo para los hombres.
Y la primera frase del artículo decía:
"El feminismo permitirá que los hombres sean libres por primera vez."
Gracias
(Aplausos)